It's about time
Ah, the
same sentence It
seems that neither of you was selected as
a veteran.
As expected, I'm looking forward to the results
.
Please give me a
draft
. Did I become a retired hero? There's
no way I'll
tell you, right? Or will you
tell me if I
ask?  If that's the case, it
's not a sign that you've moved You
're not stupid enough to be seen
through I had a hard time fighting against me when I was in poor health, so if it
was her, I'd try to regenerate her
The results of the last exam, if anyone knows,
it's not difficult
Dal
Um  There are only a limited number of people who can put their thoughts into practice under the circumstances.It
's not a strategy that a serious person like you can come up
with.  It's hard to say,
but it's probably goldfish droppings at most.
Strong research, this is a game.
It
's not my enemy,
it's just a
sudden moment.It goes without saying who's responsible for Horikita.He's
showing his willingness to fight while being restrained by
them.It doesn't seem like I need to care.  na